[Music]
can we get my mom on the phone
hey what's going on everybody from first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by Nick Offerman
he's an actor you probably know best
from his role as the revered Ron Swanson
on Parks and Recreation he's also a New
York Times bestselling author and you
can catch him live on the all rise tour
visit Offerman woodshop comm for more
information
Nick Offerman welcome to the show so
thank you what's your head space right
now how are you a spicy food
I'm okay generally I can handle most
food but I don't seek out the the crazy
flaming foods I'm looking forward to
getting an education
[Music]
okay oh that's way too hot it's
delightfully spicy I call that piquant
so obviously we have to take a wing to
discuss Ron Swanson a character whose
legend has seemingly only grown since
the days of Parks and Recreation how
familiar are you with Ron Swanson's
place in internet culture and you get a
kick out of seeing the second life the
character has had and meme form well
it's pretty inexplicable I mean I get a
great deal of fan art and the memes and
the now the deep fake videos they're
quite entertaining I'm always grateful
knowing how the Internet operates that
no one makes a huge ass out of me
that people are generally kind to me or
like use me to get a laugh I was just
glad to have a good acting job so the
fact that it has life beyond that I
think is good free advertising so I know
that the topic of where Ron Swanson ends
and where Nick Offerman begins its
well-worn territory at this point but if
you'll humor me I want to hit you with a
few of the Internet's favorite Ron
Swanson isms
I'm just curious the degree to which
they resonate with Nick Offerman dear
frozen-yogurt
you are the celery of desserts be ice
cream or be nothing zero stars in
reality I guess I'm more open-minded to
all things than Ron Swanson is pretty
strict with his rules
I not only like frozen yogurt but I like
celery alright never half asked two
things always hold ass one thing now
this that could have been spoken by my
dad he always said if you're gonna do a
job do it right and so I've always tried
to stick with that edict
again I did not come up with that line
but I do live by that standard and one
more for you give a man a fish and you
feed him for a day don't teach a man to
fish and you feed yourself he's a grown
man and fishing isn't that hard sure
that I think that makes a lot of sense
we're two mollycoddling in this modern
age of consumerism where you are never
left on your own to learn to survive so
I think I think we should send our kids
out into the woods naked with maybe a
ball of string and and a fish hook if
you want a pamper Chicago sweet home
unimpressed so far that's only delicious
well enjoy these moments soak it in you
know this is nothing so I know that you
grew up in Minooka
Illinois a town that I think I used to
drive through my way to the University
of Illinois down I 55 just south of
Joliet there you would've passed
Channahon are our twin village Manuka
was next to Shannon Manuka had an exit
on route 80 was unofficial st. Patrick's
Day a thing when you're at the
University of Illinois or did that
happen afterwards must've been after me
that doesn't ring a bell
and then did you have a favorite on
campus landmark did you ever like go to
those marl plots where they had the
experimental cornfields the there was an
incredible landmark that is still there
called the Japan house which is just a
little bit east of the Moro plots down
on South Florida where it's this super
authentic Japanese tea house where you
can learn Japanese tea ceremony and
ikebana flower arrangement all these
Japanese arts in a park-like setting
it's incredibly beautiful and so I still
go back and visit it to this day
[Music]
pineapple habanero bring it I taste the
pineapple I taste the habanero I believe
that this is from Thunder Bay Ontario
that's where it's from Thunder Bay shout
out Thunder Bay have you ever been not
to my knowledge but I have a feeling my
wife might be calling the bathroom
Thunder Bay for a couple nights after
this so you once told bone Appetit if
properly dried and trimmed New York
style pizza can be used to make a box
for Chicago style pizza a quote that
establishes you as both a handyman in a
biased Illinois native my first of all
that was an awesome burn I'm very proud
of it buddy
you know that's me being funny deep-dish
pizza is amazing and the main difference
is one slice of deep-dish pizza is two
meals as opposed to you need kind of a
whole pie of New York Pizza to equal one
slice and I'm a Midwestern ER so we like
our portions you know thicker is better
that said I'm perfectly fine with a New
York slice as well it's also kick-ass
pizza and then I know that you're a
seasoned cook and a great supporter of
the bratwurst do you have a go-to
bratwurst recipe no I I'm very simple so
I like to I boil my bratwurst in beer
yes okay yes I do have a recipe I boil
them in beer and then throw them on the
grill and I like to get them as
caramelized as possible
and then I just have it with raw chopped
onion and stone-ground mustard that's
the way to do it now don't screw it up
[Music]
that's that last one is sneaking up on
me I'm still with you I can still form
sentences well that's a good thing
because as nick offerman fans know you
can speak eloquently on almost anything
but I think that you are your most
poignant when you're railing against
consumerism and the sort of
technological breakthroughs that are
designed to make our lives easier why
does the phrase Pizza Delivery by drone
make you bristle mom I'm a human being
with the rest of us so all of these
luxuries I get it I mean the thing that
whatever you're watching us on right now
is supercool you know if you'd told me
when I was in high school that I'd be
eating hot wings and people were
watching it on a weird little
technological rectangle in a parking lot
somewhere right probably crying I would
be amazed
but having pizza delivered by a flying
robot yeah that's awesome in a lot of
ways but then we forget to ask questions
like who's making this pizza where is it
coming from is it good for me you know
if we indulge in industrial consumerism
we run out of natural resources climate
change happens and suddenly we're like
well it's apocalyptic outside but at
least we can get pizza delivered by a
drone what's your take on self-driving
cars thumbs down I mean again to me I
want to be responsible for my own safety
I don't want to hand that off to a
corporation and when I'm on the road I
want to worry about other human beings
paying attention not that like somebody
software update is gonna keep their car
from hitting me as a furniture maker
yourself what are your thoughts on these
ready-to-assemble big-box retailers like
IKEA any piece of furniture that you can
make even if it looks more crappy than
an IKEA piece or or a big box you know I
hate to crap on just IKEA because I
think they're a good company in a lot of
ways but those things are made to be
disposable and they add to the landfill
it all adds to the problem but if you
can take the time to use tools learn to
use materials
that are locally sourced you can make
things that will last a lot longer and
maybe it's an ugly coffee table but by
the time it gets to your grandkids it
has a lot of charm and character
oh yeah that's that ugly coffee table
that my grandma or grandpa made me and
then as the Chicago Cubs diehard give
any thoughts on the recent five hundred
fifty million dollar stadium renovation
like is that sort of thing inevitable at
some point or is it a little sad to see
a head-to-toe makeover of the friendly
confines well I was there a lot this
year
and the nice thing is it still really
feels like Riblet Wrigley Field there
there are accessories sort of out and
about the park that feel fresh and
modern and feel pretty great actually
I mean it was the ballpark of my youth
and it's kind of crappy
and so the makeover to me just feels
like they've upgraded the bathroom
towards like oh it doesn't smell like
urine inherence that's nice but the ivy
is still on the walls and the hotdogs
are just as mediocres ever
[Music]
torchbearer sauces ghostpepper it says
on the label that's frightening but it
is gluten-free thankfully because I was
getting loaded up on glutens alright I
have a turning point a little bit on
this one yeah I feel like it's ghosting
my taste book you really that ghost is
really coming through right here my
well-being is ghosting me later bro
an agree every crank segment on our show
called explain that Graham where we do a
deep dive on our guests Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context we'll just pop them up on the
monitor here you just tell us the bigger
story and this first one it looks like
you're meeting mr. t backstage at Conan
that's right
do you remember this very well yeah it
was my first visit to Conan's show when
he was in New York I was with my wife
who was appearing on the show as a guest
so I was just mr. Mullaly and mr. T was
there and I grew up I mean I in the
Chicago area where he's from he became a
famous bouncer first and there was some
TV show there was a bouncer competition
if you can find it there's a make that
an American Idol for bouncers absolutely
and they and so like one of the the
events I remember as they had a little
stunt man with like a harness and the
bouncer had to pick him up and see who
could throw him the farthest so remember
mr. t from that show and then he became
this public figure impossibly and ended
up on the a-team so I was a huge mr. t
fan and he also had his home message of
like treat your mother right and use
good manners so I've always really loved
you know a big tough guy who also was
sensitive and promoted that so when I
met him I just was absolutely blown away
he did a really funny series with Conan
for a while where they would go out and
pick apples together in the fall I'm the
greatest thing about this picture when I
got it back was to see that my skull was
the same size as mr. T's validating
made me feel like a full-grown man
firefire scorpion for pepper sauce
blender yeah it's not cold so you've
been upheld as a paragon of manhood in
this day and age when the very tenants
of masculinity are probably more hotly
debated than ever when people can
survive perfectly well without knowing
how to build a fire fix a leaky faucet
what do you think is lost when people
stop being here well nobody told me
we're gonna go deep on this trip I'm
grateful a great question I first thing
I get accused a lot of being manly or
masculine and what I suppose some of
that must be true but I come by and
honest it's nothing that's what it's
what I was born with I look and sound
like this but I'm actually a very
talented ballet dancer
you'd be surprised to learn I feel like
everybody across the spectrum of
sexuality should know how to use a
screwdriver or should be able to change
it I'm open go for broke repeat thank
you fire fire
you know things break and those of us
who know how to fix things when they
break just end up being better
responsible members of our community I'm
gonna have a little milk
I believe I've heard that helps how
about this with a flaming tongue do you
want to stop before I go go for it I
just have one more follow-up for you as
a student of language do you think that
it makes more sense to refer to people
who are maybe in a moment of weakness as
nutsacks rather than [ __ ] since the
testicles are much more vulnerable well
I I'm a writer and I'm also a writer of
comedy I perform the I tour as a
comedian and so I often have to deal
with this issue where if I in the past
would have called somebody a [ __ ] or
something or a [ __ ] or something I now
stop myself and say okay I don't want to
do that because that I think fortifies
the gender is a ssin I'm trying to work
against but that's where it gets hard
where it's like well
traditionally that's the word that works
best that's what I learned in the locker
room as a kid you know sometimes the
words are not going to be as chewy
they're not gonna work as well but I
think slowly we're just gonna have to
keep evolving but hopefully you're in
this in this studio today will be
neither [ __ ] or my sex
[Music]
can we get my mom on the phone I
shouldn't be reading these labels to not
help sexy out a little bit cuz you see
like ghost Carolina Reaper whoo mm-hmm
I'll give this one five fires so I take
a wing to discuss woodworking a hobby of
yours that's permeated everything from
the characters you play to the books
that you write to your overall worldview
why is white oak the most heroic of all
woods
[Music]
why is white oak the most heroic of all
woods well most of the ships in history
that were built of wood hoped that they
were built of American white oak when
England came to America and discovered
our forests there were massive huge
white pine trees that were perfect for
the masts of ships so perfect that the
the Brits went around and marked this
slashed this arrow mark on trees all
over New England
that meant don't touch this tree it's
for the king we're gonna make it into a
ship mast they called it the King's
arrow I believe and the oak trees they
said holy cow these massive oak trees
are perfect so a great example is in the
Civil War era there was a American naval
ship called Old Ironsides and it was a
ship made of white oak and the hull the
outside of the ship was 18 inches thick
of white oak and so you know it's such a
badass wood that like it's the choice to
repel cannonballs there you have it all
right Nick how you doing
[Music]
great I forgot we even started this next
one is de bomb double scary red one
mm-hmm
beyond insanity it says seems like a
good idea
[Music]
so yeah I generally like delicious food
but I understand that people enjoy sort
of challenging themselves with spicy
sauces and flavors but I'll just take
the delicious part right generally but
I'm glad to I'm glad to go on this
journey with you it's it's us together
it's us together Nick I'm glad I'm
sitting down you do I feel like I might
blast off here in a second let me know
if I start lactating I'm on it Dom you
on it mmm check the monitors mm-hmm
what do you find funny about middling
authority figures I've heard you make
that case then people who take their
positions of authority way too serious
their comedic gold yeah I feel drunk
Caliente sauce well
the specific thing about them and the
two examples I remember from my youth
are they're both high school principals
one is played by Paul Gleason he's the
principal in The Breakfast Club and the
other is Jeffrey Jones who plays the
principal in Ferris Bueller's Day Off
they've worked hard and made it to be
the principal of a school but yet nobody
is respecting them and so they take
themselves very seriously with like
people come on in sit down I'm gonna
I've got 17 rules about the faculty
parking lot Judy thank you and as I
developed into a person perfectly suited
to play that the level of mediocrity as
I go I think that could be my wheelhouse
right there did you learn anything about
that from being a bouncer cuz that's a
job where you really have to pokerface
you can't see what's wrong where are you
find me find me right to keep talking
okay just follow my voice just follow my
voice you were saying did you learn
anything about that from being a bouncer
cuz that's a job where you really have
to pokerface your authority more than
most others um yeah I somehow
intimidating people has everything to do
with your presence and I learned that on
stage also as a young man in theater
school that if you if you maintain an
intense presence people will read into
you if you're the bouncer if they're
like oh that guy's quiet
I better not mess with him but if you're
like he's over company it makes my show
don't mess with me then they're like
yeah it seems like maybe a joke all
right Nick I think that's it we did them
all whoo I didn't think we'd make it but
here we are at the end mmm
seems like we just ate a death chemical
well this next one is called burn after
eating okay I'm guessing we're tapering
back down now - yeah
returning home will landing the chop did
you guys get the two dough's yes you did
it's a hand squeeze - potato water right
there for your Ryder
[Music]
I'll be surprised if I can't sense
anything of this sauce after the last
Fox
so I've scorched earth in the mouth
after that one look I'm getting
something
woo so over the course of your career I
know that there's some dream gigs that
got away which did you pursue harder
Baywatch or Lord of the Rings
you have a fine research department I
[Music]
definitely let the yoga exist
in my sinuses I definitely pursued Lord
of the Rings much more fulsomely
because that was something I desperately
wanted to do baywatch was a joke I
really wanted to do it when I was moving
here from Chicago 20 years ago I had a
Baywatch air freshener hanging from my
rearview mirror as I told all my friends
I'm drunk I'm gonna drive west until I
get to this goddamn thing it's like
putting a motivational quote on the
mirrors it really was and I mean you
know I was auditioning for something and
the casting director also cast Baywatch
somehow the storyline ended up on the
Gulf Coast and there were some like
scary hillbillies or something she was
like oh we actually you know normally I
wouldn't think twice looking at you for
Baywatch but we do have some scary
rednecks coming up and so I did get some
for it to no avail
Lord of the Rings I was was much more
much more forceful I sent letters to
Peter Jackson and I wrote all these
letters cuz I really wanted to play
Samwise Gamgee that's me that's the best
part in those books
Peter I did not respond to my letters to
this day he's not written me back and
don't think I'm not bearing a grudge but
I did eventually through the normal
channels I made it to where they called
me in in you know the huge group to put
me on tape reading for the role of Gimli
the dwarf spoiler alert
didn't go my way
alright next so this is the last dab we
call it the last a because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing you'd always have
to if you don't want to well if you're
gonna do a job do it right I believe I
heard on a a pithy YouTube show oh yeah
love the form you call it the last dev I
call it the money shot you I changed the
name now mmm right across the thigh
[Music]
this one there's three X's on it but I
don't I mean I don't really care about
living anymore
Wow yep but the good news is Nick that
we've made it here we're halfway now
bring out the hot ones we've gone
through and we've explored the many
Renaissance like talents from word
working to acting to writing books and
we've been regaled by your silver tongue
and now with the hot sauce setting your
brain ablaze I think it's time to put
that to the test we've pulled some SATs
style vocabulary words I'll just show
them to you and if you can try to define
and put in a sentence okay piquant these
chicken wings have grown progressively
more and more [ __ ] piquant
dexterous when I walked in here my
tongue was much more dexterous than it
is now after becoming numb from hot
sauce thespian many people think that
I'm a professional jackass but I correct
them and tell them I'm a classically
trained thespian unctuous I like to
think that my jokes are quite enjoyable
but often at family gatherings they find
me rather unctuous well you know what I
don't think there's anything unctuous
about you and Nick Offerman and look at
you taking on the wings of death ten
chicken wings up ten chicken wings down
and now I think it is time for a toast
Lagavulin yeah this is coming out in a
couple weeks
this was my character scotch on Parks
and Rec and that led to us shooting in
Scotland at their distillery and we hit
it off can you smell that already I do
it's like a campfire and it smells like
victory and now Nick Offerman there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life okay
well I'm touring a comedy show called
all rise I sing and I talk about funny
things you can find out about tickets
for that at Offerman woodshop calm but
perhaps most importantly we're gonna
toast with a Lagavulin eleven-year
Offerman special edition single malt
scotch Cheers
two hot ones
[Music]
it's the spot just right so just just
short of insurance went just like I
thought it would accept your questions
were or good we're better than I thought
they would be for a chicken wing YouTube
show yeah you never know
hey really never know
what's up spice Lords og camera guy bill
here back in the studio you thought it
was a one hit one to think again son I'm
bringing the heat it's the last death
xxx xxxx turning you into Phi breathe
and tear xxx worse than Godzilla
stopping on Tokyo send your taste was
packin go go go - a glass of milk -
chill me down first we feast breathe the
heat we included around toughen winter
xxx call me Xander cage Mouse throwing
fireballs chaotic evil main role in the
20s crit hit the next era T tearing up
so much you can no longer see it Sochi
camera got bill you think you know me
but so hot you'll [ __ ] your pants Bobby
Lee oh did something just happen
sausage Superman leaves you rekt
supervillain heat call in the legs
shooting laser beam straight from the
tongue take another damn ko now you done
son
what it is oh gee camera got bill 2019 I
bring the heat triple letter selects
[Music]